I'm not the only one trying to teach the
nation how to cook there are loads of
chefs at it the number of cookery
courses available in the UK has
increased by 70% in 10 years it's a
multi-million pound industry so I'm
going to road-test the schools to see
what's on offer and to see what I can
get away with I don't want any special
treatment so the only way to do this is
to go undercover later I'll be getting a
whole new face but first I need to
develop a new persona time for some
acting lessons hello great lovers that
better not make me pretend to be a
[ __ ] tree it's a big challenge for
Gordon to move away from his physicality
he's very pronounced obvious gestures
direct punchy [ __ ] [ __ ] we'll be taking
you from this kind of circle which is
where all your gestures tend to be and
saying okay from now on no gestures
above this line in the body so it'd be
like imagining there was an invisible
shield really yes ah yeah I've got that
like you're turning me into a wing
the aim of the training is to transform
me into James
I wonder if is possible for you drank a
61 year old retired teacher from
Edinburgh can with the [ __ ] wait so
that's just it on doesn't scratch James
doesn't sweat no so maybe talk about
yeah I don't know it doesn't work stage
2 time for something I've always wanted
a facelift my Craigie forehead is a dead
giveaway so I've had some
state-of-the-art prosthetics made from a
cast of my head
am i that [ __ ] wrinkly but there is
that real [ __ ]
hey we've taken the cast support so that
everything is designed to fit Gordon's
face exactly so it should move and
respond to react with Gordon's face
these guys are experts and make all the
monsters on Doctor Who
after two hours in makeup my face feels
completely alien I like [ __ ] Freddy
Krueger I'm not totally convinced by my
new persona so before I go face to face
with Britain's top cooks I want to try
out my accent on a friend of 15 years
hello San Angela who you doing my name
is James
oh [ __ ] balls rumbled part one stuffed
part two I'm [ __ ] myself